OK, Martin says, are most business owners on Angie's
home advisor paying for leads?
I thought only it says sponsored or verified.
Yes, well, it depends.
Not all, not all are on.
And that's why I prefer Google ads.
Somebody's paying for Google ads.
You see, it says sponsored.
That means they're currently paying.
Home advisor angels doesn't necessarily mean they're paying.
So what I'll do is I've in my head, I'm assuming they're not.
I'm assuming they maybe got verified and they were paying.
But you know, the annoying thing with home advisor,
they can turn it off, they can turn it on.
So I assume that they're not.
But I still in my head, I'm like, at one point,
they went through the process of getting on home advisor
and they might still be paying.
So I would prefer they're paying for Google ads.
But no, that doesn't always mean that they're currently paying.